and keep the virus down but there's a
knock-on effect of that
which is lots of young people in
hospitality nhs workers and so on
uh people might be off work when they're
needed in work
okay well we'll see if boris johnson the
prime minister can make sense of it all
when he faces questions do stay with us
they're getting ready in the house of
commons in a moment we will bring you
at noon prime minister's questions
[Music]
well welcome back to sky news at noon
prime minister's question is just about
to get underway liz truss
the international trade secretary just
finishing
her questions session there with me uh
beth rigby our political editor and beth
um this is not going to be the last of
mr johnson's public appearances today
no this is this is the warm-up hack for
him today because after pmq's he has the
liaison committee you remember that this
is
a committee of all the senior heads of
select committees and groove them get
together
and they have a couple of hours with
which they can ask the prime minister
questions that they want today on the
agenda is obviously covered so there'll
be lots of probing
on the coveted policy going into the
summer and the autumn let's see if they
look retrospectively
to some of the decisions that have been
made
and also there's going to be questions
around cop that's the big climate change
summit in november
in glasgow here he is mr johnson on his
feet i bet he's going to talk about
football as well
we remember the 52 innocent people who
lost their lives
and those who were injured and paid
tribute to the city's
emergency services for their heroic
response
mr speaker i'm sure the whole house will
wish to join me in sending condolences
to the family and friends of
sizzling faye allen who died earlier
this week
she was the uk's first black female
police officer and she served in the
metropolitan police
mr speaker i'm sure colleagues will also
want to join in wishing the england
football team
the best of luck for tonight's
semi-final against
denmark this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues
and honors and in addition to my duties
in this house i shall have such
further such meetings later today
thank you mr speaker prime minister we
hear
a great deal on this place about the
rule of law and injustice
can the prime minister tell me what he's
going to do
about the injustice that my constituents
and falca indeed family
up and down the uk are facing every day
because of the retrospect
lonzard that is fast turning into the
next post office scandal
the hounding by hmrc clearly out of
control
accountable to no one has managed to
hoodwink mislead his own treasury
ministers and now
according to the head of hmrc the
retrospective loan charge appears to be
without any legal basis or justification
here
therefore will the prime minister accept
this market needs further
and immediate investigations
mr speaker i'm acutely aware as i think
all colleagues are around the house of
the
uh the pain suffered by those who
entered into loan charge schemes
and i think i think uh alas that they
were
misguided to do so uh but i think that
the
uh the the line taken by the treasury
i'm afraid
is right on this let's go to john
stevenson
john thank you mr speaker prime minister
there is more that unites us and divides
us is very true of the united kingdom
however improved connectivity is vital
to ensuring we remain united
the government's recent interim
connectivity review has suggested some
improvements
if this is really going to happen then
improvements must be made to the a75 the
a69
and to the extension of the borders
railway does a prime minister support
such investment
and what is the time scale for such
investment
excellent uh question i think he should
uh not have too long to wait
for the uh final recommendations from
sir peter hendy about
the a75 and other great features of
union
uh connectivity uh which th which this
government uh hopes to support but we've
already
uh agreed uh five million uh from the
uk and the scottish governments uh to
support uh the extension
of the edinburgh tweed bank borders uh
railway at akala
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister in his remarks about the
seven
seven anniversary um i remember where i
was
on that day and we'll never forget it
i'm sure that's the same for everybody
and we will never forget
all those affected especially the family
and friends of all those
who died can i join the prime minister
in his comments about faye failing
as well and also about football and wish
the very best of luck
to the england football team this
evening i'm sure the whole
country with the possible exception of
the conservative mp for ashfield
will be watching this evening and
cheering england
on mr speaker can i also extend a
special welcome
to the new member for batley and spain
and will members opposite forgive me if
i just turn round
um to look at the new member for
batman's bender she sits there on these
benches
beneath the flat to joe cox her sister
and that's a special an emotional moment
for all of us
on these benches and i i think for
everybody across this
house it takes incredible courage and
bravery
to stand in that constituency
and to sit on these benches beneath that
plaque
mr speaker we all want our economy to
open and to get back to
normal the question is whether we do it
in a controlled way
or a chaotic way the health secretary
told the house yesterday
that under the government's plan
infections could go
as high as a hundred thousand a day now
a number of key questions
fall from that first if infections reach
that level a hundred thousand
per day what does the prime minister
expect the number of hospitalizations
deaths and the number of people with
long covered
will be in that eventuality prime
minister
mr speaker the uh there are a number of
uh projections
uh and that they're available from the
from the spy m
graphs but which certainly true mr
speaker that we are seeing
a wave of of cases because of the
the delta variant but uh scientists are
also absolutely clear
uh that we have severed the link uh
between uh
infection and serious disease and death
and and currently there are only
uh a thirtieth of of the of the deaths
that we were seeing
at an equivalent position in previous
waves
of this uh pandemic and that has been
made possible
thanks to the vaccine rollout uh the
fastest of any
european country and i think what people
would like to hear from
the party opposite because i wasn't
quite clear from that opening question
is whether or not they support the
progress that this country
is intending to make on july the 19th
or not mr speaker he says it's a
reckless to go ahead does that mean he's
opposing it
mr speaker we know that the link between
infection rates and deaths has been
weakened but it hasn't been broken
and the prime minister must and he
certainly should know the answer to the
question that i asked him
that he won't answer it here in the
house hardly inspires confidence in his
plan
mr speaker let's be clear why infection
rates are so clear
so high because the prime minister let
the delta
or we can call it the johnson variant
into the country
and let's be clear let's be clear why
the number of cases will
surge so quickly because he is taking
all protections off in one go
that is reckless the sage papers
yesterday
mr speaker make clear that with high
infection rates
there's a greater chance of new variants
emerging
greater pressure on the nhs more people
will get long covered
and test and trace will be less
effective knowing all that
is the prime minister really comfortable
with a plan that means a hundred
thousand people catching this virus
every day and everything that that
entails
[Applause]
mr speaker i really think we need to
hear uh from what the
uh the general what he actually uh
supports uh we will continue
with a balanced and unreasonable
approach and i've given the the reasons
this country has rolled out the fastest
vaccination program
uh anywhere in europe the the vaccines
provide
more than 90 percent uh protection
against hospitalization
both of them mr speaker by the 19th of
july
uh we will have vaccinated uh every
adult would have been offered
one vaccination uh everybody over 40 mr
speaker will have been offered uh two
uh vaccinations that is an extraordinary
achievement that's
allowing us to go ahead now last week uh
mr speaker
earlier this week uh he seemed to
support opening up
uh getting rid of the one meter rule he
seemed to support uh getting back into
nightclubs and uh and getting back into
pubs without masks
mr speaker but if he doesn't support him
perhaps he could clear it up now
is it reckless or not mr speaker
mr speaker we should we should open up
in a controlled way
keeping keeping base license protections
such as mars on public transport
improving ventilation
making sure the track and trace system
remains effective and ensuring proper
payments for self-isolation
the prime minister can't just wish away
the practical problems that a hundred
thousand infection a day are going to
cause
don't wish them away the next obvious
one is the huge number of people who be
asked to isolate
if there are a hundred thousand
infections a day that means hundreds of
thousands perhaps
millions of people are going to be
pinged to isolate
the financial times estimates this
morning that that could be
around 2 million people per week the
mail says 3.5 million people
a week either way it's a massive number
it means huge disruption
to families and businesses just as the
summer holidays begin
so we know what the ft thinks we know
what the male thinks what their
estimates are
can the prime minister tell us how many
people does he expect
will be asked to isolate if infection
rates continue to rise at this rate
mr speaker i want to thank everybody who
self-isolates
they're doing the right thing they're a
vital part of this country's protection
against the
against the disease and what we'll be
doing is
moving away from self-isolation uh
towards uh testing
in the course of the next few weeks and
that is the prudent approach because we
all have mr speaker
vaccinated even more people but what he
what he can't explain he can't have it
both ways he says it's reckless
it's reckless to open up mr speaker and
yet he attacks
yet he attacks self-isolation mr speaker
which is one of the key
protections that this country has and
let me ask him again
uh he's on monday he seemed to say he
was in favor
he seemed to say he was in favor of
opening up on july the 19th
now he's saying it's records which is it
mr speaker
maybe i can help a little just to remind
us that it's prime minister's questions
if we want if we want opposition
questions we'll need to change
the question was simply how many people
are going to be asked to self-isolate if
there's a hundred thousand infections a
day and he won't answer it
and we know why he won't answer and
pretends i'm asking a different question
he ignored the problems in schools now
the seven hundred thousand children off
per week because he ignored it
now he's ignoring the next big problem
that's heading down the track
and gonna affect millions of people who
have to self-isolate
now it won't feel like freedom day to
those who have to isolate when they're
having to cancel their holidays
when they can't go to the pub or even to
their kids sports day
and it won't feel like freedom day prime
minister to the businesses
who are already warning of carnage
because of the loss
of staff and customers it must be
obvious with case rates that high his
plan risks undermining the track and
trace system
that he spent billions and billions of
pounds on
prime minister there are already too
many stories of people deleting the nhs
app he must have seen those stories and
they're doing it because they can see
what is coming down the track
now of course we don't support that mr
speaker
but under his plan it's entirely
predictable what is the prime minister
going to do to stop people deleting the
nhs track
because they can see precisely what he
can't see which is millions of them are
going to be pinged
this summer to self-isolate
mr speaker of course we're going to
continue with the
uh programme of uh of self-isolation for
long as that is
necessary i thank all those who are uh
who are
doing it but of course what we're also
doing
is moving to a system of testing rather
than
self-isolation and we can do that we can
do that because of the massive
rollout of the vaccine and what i'm
still not
and i think about the fourth or fifth
time mr speaker it's still not clear
whether he's actually in favor of this
country moving forward
to step four on the basis of the massive
role artifacts
and yes of course mr speaker this is
unlike the law
where you can you can attack from lots
of different positions at once
to oppose you must have a credible and
clear
alternative and i simply do not hear
is he is he in favor of us moving
forward
yes or no it's completely impossible to
tell
justin once again it's prime minister's
questions and the prime minister answers
questions
if he stopped mumbling and listened he'd
have heard the answer the first time
we want to open we want to open
we want to open in a controlled way and
keep in line
baseline protections that can keep down
infections
like mandatory face marks on face masks
on public transport now we know that
that will protect people
reduce the speed of the virus and the
spread of the virus and it won't harm
the
economy it's common sense why can't the
prime minister see that
by minister i of course mr speaker we
can
see that it's common sense uh for people
in confined spaces
uh to wear a face mask out of respect
and courtesy
uh to others but such as on the on the
tube but what we're doing mr speaker
is is cautiously prudently moving to
from
a legal dictat from legal dictat
to allowing people to take personal
responsibility
for their actions and that is the that
is the right way forward mr speaker
i must say that if really that is the
only difference between us if he
supports
absolutely everything else uh so opening
pubs opening nightclubs
uh getting rid of the two getting rid of
the one meter rule getting people back
to work and it all it's all about
whether the difference between
uh making face masks mandatory or
advisory on the tube if that is the only
difference between us mr speaker
then that is good news uh but i'd like
to hear him clarify that
mr speaker he agrees it's public
it's common sense because it protects
the public but he
won't make it mandatory it's ridiculous
it's clear what this is all
about he's lost a health secretary
he's lost a by-election and he's getting
flack from his own mps
so he's doing what he always does
crashing over to the other side of the
aisle
chasing headlines and coming up with a
plan that hasn't been
thought through we all want restrictions
lifted
we want our economy open and we want to
get back to normal but we've been here
too many times before isn't it the case
that once again
instead of a careful controlled approach
we're heading for a summer of chaos and
confusion
[Applause]
[Music]
uh no mr speaker is the answer to that
and
these are of course these are these are
difficult decisions they need to be
taken in a
in a balanced way and that's what we're
doing and uh throughout the pandemic
to do all these things uh frankly mr
speaker takes a great deal of drive and
it takes a great deal of leadership
to get things done and if we if we
followed his advice
mr speaker if we followed his advice we
would still be in the european medicines
agency
and we would never well absolutely we
would never have rolled out
uh the vaccines as fast as if we
followed his advice mr speaker
we would never have got schools open
again with all the damage
to kids uh education and frankly mr
speaker
if we listen to him if we listen to him
we would not
now be proceeding cautiously
pragmatically sensibly
to reopen our society and our economy
and give people back the chance to enjoy
the freedoms
they love we're getting on with taking
the tough decisions to take this country
forward
mr speaker we vaccinate they vacillate
we we inoculate mr speaker
while they're invertebrate
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker last week i visited
pence south primary school in warrington
to talk to year 6 children about how we
can generate
cleaner energy in the future does the
prime minister agree with me that as
well as backing electric vehicle
production in the northwest
there's a great opportunity to shift
towards low carbon hydrogen
by providing support for projects such
as high net northwest
which by 2030 will secure thousands of
green jobs in the northwest
as well as by cutting emissions to the
same level as taking four million cars
off the roads
yes mr speaker i believe that northwest
in addition to uh
the rest of this country can uh be a
world leader will be a world leader in
hydrogen technology and
i think the high net project is an
excellent example
uh we've already put 445 million into
supporting
uh the high net project kickstarting our
hydrogen capture and
uh storage and i thank him uh for his
support we now come to the leader of the
snp
in blackfoot thank you mr speaker can i
wish england all the best for the
match tonight against denmark and i
associate myself with the
remarks of the prime minister on the
tragedy of the bombing of seven seven
that we all
remember so vividly and also mr speaker
yesterday was the 33rd anniversary
of the paper alpha disaster 167 people
cruelly
lost their lives and our thoughts are
very much with the friends and family
that are still grieving
over the terrors of uh of that event and
and finally before i
move on this is also serenity memorial
week and we should be remembering
those that have suffered at genocide
whether that be in
bosnia in the holocaust in the wonder
and many other places and perhaps the
prime minister will meet with me to
discuss how we can help
the the seven eliza charity here in the
uk
mr speaker this week the tory government
introduced
its so-called electoral integrity bill
in reality the bill is designed to do
anything but
increase the integrity of our elections
it is a solution
in desperate search of a problem that
simply does not exist
what the bill will do is to impose for
the first time
trumpian voter id laws in the uk
the electoral reform society says it
could lead to voter
disenfranchisement on an industrial
scale
disenfranchising people from working
class communities
bme communities and others already
marginalized in society
creating barriers to vote prime minister
why is this tory government trying to
rob people
of their democratic right to vote
[Music]
mr speaker what we're trying to protect
is the democratic right of
uh people to have a one person one vote
system and uh i'm afraid that i have
personal experience i remember
vividly uh what used to go on in uh
tower hamlets
uh and i think it is important that we
move to uh some sort of
uh some sort of voter id and plenty of
other
uh countries have it uh and it's i think
it eminently sensible people i think
will be
reassured that their votes matter and
that's what this bill
is about goodness gracious prime
minister come on there were 34
allegations
of impersonation in 2019 this is a
problem that does not exist
it is a british prime minister seeking
to make it harder to vote
because it's easier to get re-elected if
the government can choose the voters
rather than letting the voters choose
their government
mr speaker three and a half million
people in the united kingdom do not have
a form of photo id
11 million people do not have a passport
or driver's license these millions of
people
will be directly impacted by seeing the
right to vote
curtailed and it's not just the
opposition saying this
members of the prime minister's own
party have called his plans
an illogical and a liberal solution to a
non-existent problem
mr speaker will the prime minister
withdraw these
vote rigging proposals immediately or he
will continue down the path
of being a tin pot dictator
right uh well mr speaker i look i think
he's making a bit of a mansion out of a
motive i may
if i may respectfully uh suggest uh
councils will be under an obligation to
provide free photo id to anybody uh who
wants it and i do think it reasonable
uh to protect the public uh in our
elections
uh from the idea of voter fault nobody
wants to see it no and by the way
i don't think the elections in this
country should be in any way clouded or
contaminated
by the suspicion of voter fraud and
that's what we're trying to
prevent thank you very much mr speaker
and i was pleased to see my right
honourable friend in cornwall
for a very successful g7 summit
whilst i know he didn't manage to get
south east cornwall
i can assure him that lou is a very
beautiful coastal town
the problem is lou floods regularly
will my right honourable friend speak to
government departments
to get this sorted all right
[Music]
through my honourable friend just uh uh
thank again the people of cornwall
southeast cornwall everybody
had it was a wonderful hospitality that
the g7 had
uh and i assure her that i i'm aware of
the problem
of the flooding uh in lieu and uh i can
tell
her that uh my right honourable friend
the environment secretary
uh has met cornwall council to discuss
the matter and we will do everything we
can
to sort it out thank you mr speaker
and i'd like to add my uh voice on
behalf of the album party to the
comments about seven seven on the
morning of seven seven hours at a
meeting at ucla
e as the um information started coming
through and i would pay tribute to every
single one of those
uh frontline staff that i worked
alongside on that day
it was a long shift and it was a long
walk home that evening
the prime minister talks about vaccines
accurate surveillance is
really important as well it's equally as
important and on the 15th of march the
department of health social care
minister lord bethel on twitter said
that omega diagnostics and
logic where in line for 2 million
lateral flow device
order per day by the end of may
promise jobs and security so
can the prime minister explain why his
government
is undermining the superior domestic
diagnostics test
while cropping up um discredited chinese
imports
to the tune of three billion pounds
i thank the uh honorable i don't think
that's entirely
uh fair characterization of what the
government is is doing
uh on on the contrary we have worked
night and day to build up our domestic
natural flow uh capacity and and
continue uh to do so
mr speaker last week president xi
cheerily threatened that any foreigners
attempting to influence china
will have their heads bashed against the
great wall of steel
and of course he's still in denial about
human rights violations and the
genocides in xi jin
and tibet as recognized by this house
and as a result of which five of us
remain sanctioned
so will the prime minister therefore
support our motion to be debated in this
house next thursday
calling for a diplomatic boycott of the
2022 winter olympics
incredibly awarded to beijing until and
unless
this dangerous regime abides by basic
international standards of decency
i thank my friend but this country has
led the world in condemning human rights
abuses in
in xinjiang and putting sanctions on
those uh responsible
uh in uh in holding companies to account
uh that
that that import uh goods made with
forced labor
in in xinjiang and i will certainly
consider the uh the proposal
uh debated but i must say that i'm uh
instinctively and always have been
against
sporting boycotts mr mr and agenda thank
you mr speaker may i associate myself
with the remarks of prime minister and
others on the anniversary
has been marked today now this sunday
11th july marks two years since the
government committed to reforming a
cruel aspect of the welfare system
which forces terminally ill people to
prove that they have six months or less
to live before their granted fast access
to benefits and the motor neuron disease
association money curiosity in that time
7 000 people have died waiting for a
decision on their benefits claim
and with the pandemic and the nhs
managing that and the backlog of
diseases
this situation will only become more
acute when will the government publish
its review
and finally scrap the six-month rule as
it has committed to do so
i'm great thank you the honourable lady
i'm aware of the issue that uh she's
raised to the best of my knowledge we
are making that change but i will
i will write her as soon as i have that
information david jones
thank you mr speaker um whilst the
extension of the grace period for the
uh supply of chilled meat from great
britain to northern ireland is welcome
lord frost is entirely right to say that
it amounts in truth to no more than a
temporary sticking plaster
so can my right honourable friend please
confirm
that unless the european union adopts a
more proportionate approach
to the application of the northern
ireland protocol
this country will do whatever it is
necessary legislative or otherwise to
fix the problem permanently
my right honourable friend is uh sadly
completely right in his
analysis there remain uh very serious
problems in the
uh what i believe is the misapplication
the excessively uh legally
purest application of that of that deal
uh and of that protocol and what we are
hoping for
uh is some progress from the european uh
commission
uh some uh some repairs that i think
that they should make to the way this is
uh that is working uh but uh to echo
what he
has said uh we certainly rule uh nothing
out
in our approach angela prime minister
one in four pregnancies end in
miscarriage
and therefore does the prime minister
agree that parents grief
for this profound loss is not an illness
therefore
parents should receive formal
miscarriage leave
rather than resort to sick pay or unpaid
leave
if their pregnancy miscarriage occurs
before
24 weeks will the prime minister support
my private members bill and introduce
paid miscarriage leave for parents
yeah prime minister
well mr speaker i i sympathize deeply
with anybody who's
uh suffered the the loss of uh of a baby
uh by a by miscarriage of course and
um uh what i can tell her is that
uh we are uh we did in
uh introduce in 2020 paid uh parental
bereavement leave
but uh what we that in fact that
entitles are those who lose a child
uh after 24 weeks of pregnancy
uh to uh to to some uh payment but
of course nothing i can say no payment
uh we could make
would be any consolation uh to those who
experience a miscarriage in that way
mr speaker the serious fraud office
achieved a rare success
in southern solid crown court in april
with a successful prosecution of gpt
special projects which resulted in 28
million pounds of penalties for
corruption
the key whistleblower in this case was
my constituent ian foxley
without whom the prosecution would never
have happened
yet he's been totally hurt to dry by the
series fraud office
despite 10 years of financial
devastation
does my right to my friend agree that
unless we properly compensate
whistleblowers
they simply will not come forward and
would he consider making a payment
out of the 28 million pounds received
from hit
by the hm treasury to compensate him for
his losses
um well i've i thank him for his
excellent question i want to thank mr
foxley
uh for his whistleblowing because he has
seen uh justice done the trouble is we
don't normally
uh compensate whistleblowers in the in
the way that he uh
he recommends but i know that my right
old friend the solicitor general has
offered to to meet
uh my old friend to discuss the matter
further
thank you mr speaker on monday we
celebrated the 73rd birthday of the nhs
one of the very best things about
our country now many of us on this side
of the house and our constituents remain
committed to protect the fundamental
right of universal health care free at
the point of delivery
but this government remains a constant
threat to our public health service
no staff pay rise a 25 cut in the number
of mental health beds and the widespread
sell-off of gp practices like the edith
cavall surgery and my constituency
to american private insurance giant
sentinel and
also just to mention the health and care
bill which will only open the doors for
privatization wider
why is the prime minister continuing to
evacuate our most essential
public services and why won't he listen
to thousands of essential workers
who demonstrated on saturday to end nhs
privatization
end chronic underfunding and
understaffing and keep the nhs
public mr speaker i don't think i i i
with great respect to the to the
to the lady office member opposite i
don't think i've ever heard
a a question that was more uh inversely
related to the to the to reality uh this
is a government
this is a government uh that from the
from the the from the
beginning invested the biggest amount in
the nhs for it for a generation
then in the last year we put another 92
billion pounds mr speaker into
into frontline care uh we've increased
uh nurses pay
uh by 12 for starting by 12.8 over the
last
three years and above all mr speaker
we're not only building 48 more
hospitals
but there are another 59 000 people
working in the nhs
this year than there were this time last
year this is a government that is
putting our nhs
first skill to kate rithis cage
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the whole
house welcomes the fantastic news of
nissan's investment in an electric
battery gigafactory in sunderland
but does the prime minister agree with
me that batteries are only part of the
solution
in pursuit of net zero by 2050 and that
zero carbon hydrogen combustion engines
such as those recently developed by
midlands-based jcb
have an important role to play in our
country's decarbonisation plans
minister uh my honourable friend is
completely right because
the the investments that we're seeing
just uh in the last week or so the
sunderland investment by nissan the the
the gigafactory
uh in sunderland that what stalantis uh
are doing at elsmere port these are
tremendously exciting for
battery-powered
uh vehicles it's fantastic but we must
not forget
hydrogen uh mr speaker as i said uh in
an earlier answer we want uh this
country uh to be a world leader in
hydrogen technology
as well
thank you mr speaker i know the prime
minister
is aware of the fatal and serious
accidents that take
road accidents that have taken place on
saint albans road and redborn road in my
constituency
could the prime minister advise the
house and advise me on what more the
government is doing to improve
road safety not just in the case of
fatal accidents but often
where there are serious accidents or
near misses because this is an issue
that's of growing concern
to many of my constituents and i believe
to many across the country
i i i thank my offender he's uh he's
right
to raise this although the uh those
who've been killed or seriously injured
in uh on the roads has been coming down
over a long
uh period of time it is vital uh that we
invest in this we put another hundred
million
uh pounds through the safer roads fund
uh to invest in 50 of the most dangerous
uh stretches on on a roads and i also
draw to his attention
to the think uh campaign which can play
a huge role
in reducing deaths and serious injuries
on our roads
you're pretty cool thank you mr speaker
today bitter disappointment
and despite the assurances given during
the fire safety bill that it would do so
the building safety bill published on
monday does little to help
the hundreds of thousands of
leaseholders who right now
face financial ruin as a result of the
building safety crisis
my question to the prime minister is a
simple one why is his government
seemingly intent on failing to honour
the commitments given to those
leaseholders
and members of this house by refusing to
legislate to fully protect
all the blameless victims of this
scandal
[Music]
but that's not uh accurate mr speaker we
are we are continuing
uh to uh support uh all
uh those who have to remediate uh their
buildings and i just remind you the five
billion that we've provided is five
times mr speaker what labour offered to
support
uh in their last in their last manifesto
and we will make sure that all the
leaseholders
uh people who have suffered uh from the
consequences of the grenfell
uh conflagration uh do get the advice
and the support they need
thank you mr speaker my right honourable
friend will recognize the huge service
done by
independent hospices to those at the end
of their lives
to their families and to the nhs because
these people would likely otherwise be
in hospital
he will also understand the huge impact
that the covid pandemic has had
on the fundraising capacity of these
hospice charities
so can i ask him to consider carefully
and personally the case that is being
made by independent hospices for greater
government support for their clinical
costs
costs which if they were no longer there
would undoubtedly be borne by the
taxpayer
and by the hard-pressed nhs
i i thank my right honourable friend and
he's totally
uh right to draw attention to the
incredible uh selfless work of
of hospices up and down the country
charitable hospices
uh they they do receive uh 350 million
pounds of government funding
annually his right to draw attention to
the particular difficulties they've had
in fundraising and that's this year over
the pandemic and that's why they've
received an additional
uh 257 million pounds uh in national
uh grant funding arrangements let's go
to imran hussain
imran mr speaker
in january the prime minister promised
me that he would listen to the calls of
those
that the government had excluded from
vital support to protect their jobs
businesses and incomes during the corona
virus pandemic
yet over the last six months many of my
constituents are still coming to tell me
that they have been shut off
and ignored and millions across the
country continue to be excluded
so i have to ask the prime minister why
did he give those
who have been excluded falsehood instead
of the support
they desperately needed minister
mr speaker i thank the honourable
general and of course i know how tough
it has been
for millions of people up and down the
country i know how tough it has been uh
for business but that's why
this government put in an extraordinary
407 billion pounds to support jobs and
livelihoods across the country
throughout the pandemic and the single
most important thing we can do now
for the for the individuals with the
families that he represents and i i know
that he's rightly
uh talking about today is to help our
country to get back
on its feet uh by cautiously opening up
in the way that we are
on on july the 19th uh if uh we can
uh take that step which i very much hope
that we will i hope
that it may command the support uh if
not the leader of the opposition
uh then at least of him thank you mr
speaker the river test is one of the
finest
chalk streams in the world but since may
diesel has been spilling into the river
what matters most is that the flow is
stopped and that there is an effective
cleanup
but there are many agencies involved
which has made a coordinated response
challenging
please will my right honourable friend
make sure the environment agency
natural england southern water local
authorities and defra
are all involved to solve this
environmental catastrophe together
i i thank my book which is completely
right uh all those
uh bodies are involved but the lead
agency is the environment agency
uh i know that they're in uh in touch
with her and i must say i have a very
high regard
for them and for their work mr speaker
i'm not sure the prime minister actually
uh welcomed uh
the new member the honourable member for
back-end spam but perhaps you want to
correct the record
after this they say where there's a will
there's a way
and the public will clearly welcome the
government's move
to introduce emergency legislation uh
for pubs and
bars tomorrow to be able to stay open uh
on sundays later
however the public will wonder why
tomorrow that the member for delhi
will be allowed to return to this house
and not subject to a recall despite
the being the case of a serious case of
sexual harassment
and actually the public doesn't
understand why there should be one rule
for conservative mps
and another for the rest of us so
therefore will therefore
will the prime minister will the prime
minister allow
time tomorrow for a motion to close this
loophole
and make him subject of a recall
[Applause]
first of all mr speaker uh the the
gentleman in question has
uh the sanction has come to an end and
secondly
uh he is in error the general opposite
is an error he is not a conservative
mp david davis mr speaker
this year thousands of children will die
because of the government's dramatic
cuts in international aid
top lawyers in the country advisors that
this policy is unlawful
and it's never been presented to this
house for approval
when he was previously asked by my
rightful friend for something coalfield
he
suggested the estimate spoke would be
the appropriate vote but that does not
allow us to increase
the amount of spending on this aid so i
asked the prime minister again
when are we going to get a binding vote
on the government's aid policy
uh i'm i'm i'm great with my right on my
friend but i'm assured by
my uh my right writer for the leader of
the house so that the
house was given a chance to vote on this
matter on the estimate space but but
mysteriously i chose not to
sing thank you so much mr speaker my
grandmother whom i love daily was lying
on a hospital deathbed
and none of us were allowed to be there
to comfort her in her final
moments i couldn't even carry her coffin
on my shoulders i also had to endure the
agony of watching alone
online the funeral of my uncle my
fun-loving uncle and
we were not there to comfort my
brother-in-law's father who had somehow
contracted covert in a slough care home
during his final moments all this
because we followed
government guidance having experienced
such painful
personal sacrifices like many others
imagine
our collective disgust when in order to
carry favor with the prime minister's
chief advisor
we see psycho frantic spineless
hypocritical government ministers
lining up to defend the indefensible
saying it's time to move on
with some even having the goal to tell
us that they too go for a long drive
when they need to get their eyesight
tested what an absolute disgrace and
they shall be thoroughly
ashamed of themselves so when is the
prime minister finally gonna apologize
to the nation for not mustering up some
courage and integrity
for doing the honorable thing and
sacking his chief adviser who so
shamelessly
flouted his own government guidance that
he could have regained that lost public
trust and confidence and he could have
demonstrated that it's not one rule for
him and his elite charms and another
for the rest of us
it is a very emotional prime minister
that's the best thing i can say mr
speaker is
how deeply i think uh i the government
everybody
uh sympathizes with those who have gone
through
the suffering are described by the
gentleman opposite
and no one can uh who hasn't been
through something like that can imagine
what it must feel like to be deprived of
the ability
to mourn uh properly to hold the hands
of a loved one
in their last moments in the way that uh
the honorable gentleman
describes and i know how much sympathy
there will be
uh with him uh and i i take his
uh these criticisms and most sincerely
of the government uh and everything that
we have done but all i can say we have
tried
uh throughout this pandemic to minimize
human suffering
uh to minimize loss of life and for
where we have and
for as i've said before when when he
asks me to apologize
i do i apologize uh for the suffering
that the people of this country have
endured and
all i can say is that nothing and uh i
can say or do
uh can uh take back uh
the the lost lives uh the lost time
spent
with loved ones that he describes and
i'm deeply deeply
sorry for that
point for the summer wilson figure
on the 23rd of june
my colleague
so that brings to an end uh prime
minister's questions memorable perhaps
for the prime minister wearing a
crossover george badge
anticipating the football for turning
down two invitations
to congratulate kim ledbeter the
uh sister of the murdered mp on becoming
an mp herself
in the battling spend by election and
also for seeing in blackford
in person for the snp back in the
chamber
having uh uh called in on uh
zoom uh since the beginning well let's
uh go to our
political editor beth rigby who's
listening to that and
repeated questions about the
consequences of the prime minister's
decision to open up
to which frankly he didn't give any
answers no and i think what we saw there
was
really sarcastic trying to set what he
sees will be the battle lines over
the summer where he is accusing the
prime minister of opening in a chaotic
reckless way he is saying labour would
open in a controlled way although when
you actually look at labour's policy the
only thing that they seem to be
disagreeing over
is the matter of wearing masks in
public transport and shop settings
but aside from the policy the
calculation from labour is as those
cases
rise and subject the health sector took
about 100 000 cases
a day that it's going to be hugely
disruptive for people there will be
hospitalizations there will be increased
death rates and the prime minister will
have to roll back
on what he describes as freedom day and
clearly what kierstarma is doing he's
made that calculation
and now he's trying to set the frame and
you saw this very interesting use of
language there
where he is now calling the delta
variant the johnson
variant label will hope that will state
the prime minister
didn't like that much at all uh the
other thing i thought was interesting
about what boris johnson said
was as he criticized kirsten for saying
would you back us
all don't you he also said that the link
between cases and hospitalizations had
been severed
that is not what patrick valance said on
monday
what patrick valance said the chief
scientific advisor
were the link had been weakened but it
hadn't been broken and so this is the
big gamble now going into the summer how
big does the third wave
become the government are opening up now
because they want this wave
in the summer before the autumn but will
it become so much and the pressure
becomes so much
that boris johnson has to reverse some
of the road map
and that's where labour want to make the
attack and that's where johnson
will hope that he won't have to do that
and come the autumn he will be the one
that is proved right so actually we
thought maybe july the 19th it's all
over and we kind of go back to normal
but you can see another iteration of the
political covered
debate but also in terms of the actual
virus
the third wave and what it means for our
everyday lives and
i think the message is that there is
going to be a lot of disruption for
people over the summer
as they're forced to self-isolate
because this virus will be
increasing very rapidly in terms of
transmission beth thank you very much
they're going to be more questions to
the prime minister this afternoon on the
record when he faces the liaison
committee we will have full reports on
that as well here on sky news
now today's breaking news uh
internationally the
president of haiti has been assassinated
in a nighttime attack
on his private residence president
jovano moisie
was shot dead when his home in the
capital puerto praise was stormed
by a group of armed men haiti's interim
prime minister also reported
that the first lady martin moyesi
has been hospitalized by the attack well
our
foreign affairs correspondent deborah
haynes
joins me now uh never a very happy
country haiti unfortunately
no and details are still emerging about
what happened overnight
the interim prime minister has made a
statement it seems as though
the attackers came in at about one in
the morning at this residential home and
shot dead
the president um joseph claude joseph
saying that he's going to be giving
a statement later and he he called the
attack
heinous inhuman and barbaric
but it comes at a time of increasing
political instability you'll remember
back in february the president himself
warned that
um there'd been an attempt on his life
an attempt to overthrow
his government um and a couple of dozen
people
were arrested so it's it's uh it's
happening at a point of
of huge instability the opposition
accusing uh had been accusing the
president of
um trying to turn the state into more of
a dictatorship they'd had
a failure to hold legislative elections
back in 2019 and so for the last two
years the president
has has been ruling by decree and his
actual
term it was a five-year term the length
of that has also been disputed
this is a man if you talk a little bit
about um
the now deceased president who came into
politics in 2015
he'd never been a politician before he
was hand-picked
by the previous president he's actually
um a banana entrepreneur a banana
exporter
a businessman um and in those elections
they were disputed in 2015 into 2016 and
he was only actually declared
president in february 2017.
it's a five-year term and he believe he
had believed
then his supporters believed that he
should be in office
until next year but his opposition very
much thought he should be out
already and that has fueled the anger
the protests that we've seen on the
streets
also allegations of corruption this is a
hugely um turbulent time anyway and
analysts are very worried about
potential further instability
um it seems as though there will be this
address later on today from the interim
prime minister
and the security forces will be wanting
to try to
keep calm and avoid a further escalation
thank you very much indeed for that uh
update on the situation in haiti one of
the poorest countries in the world debra
haynes thank you
you're watching sky news coming up next
can england do it tonight
why it's too early to write off denmark
you